you said you'd been here 15 years in LA
hmm from Chicago okay if there had been
a handbook that someone was going to
deliver to you and say Trey this is for
you and you will learn all this but it's
gonna take 15 years what do you wish was
in that handbook money no because you
can survive la is so expensive if you're
a struggling actor you anybody comes out
here the cost of living is so high you
can't it's hard for you to get a regular
job because you have to try to pursue
you have to do all editions it means all
that so you'll get fired or you get laid
off from your job so you had the money
to be that cushion to be able to pursue
this then yeah but as of course I guess
I'll give you another oh that's good I
like that I like that book actually I
wish someone had handed me that but what
else in that book that would tell you
different things don't waste your time
with this spend more time on that
do you wish someone had given to you but
that you've learned now that you could
then hand that book to someone here's
the irony of that because you just never
know because there's a lot of when I
first got here I were touched by some of
these different showcases or whatever
don't go there ripoff because why these
casting directors they set these
showcases a shiner make their own money
pay their own bills
but the same time because they're not
really invested to really find somebody
but if they do Oh
each pilot is guy so it's a it's not is
so unorthodox and there's nothing that's
not a set blueprints so to have that
book it's like just my experience just
experience it should be this was just
like a book of just experiences and you
just learn like wow that's why I watch
those different backstories and
everybody else because it's nothing
the most important thing is just to
commit whatever is gonna be you're gonna
do you know and ice and ice to do your
research to commit to whatever the
characters gonna be whatever things you
chew okay if you want to work at Home
Depot you know it's like you want to be
the head cashier you have to work you
have to commit to whatever it is you
know put the hours in the work so that
book mainly is just to say just to to
stay focusing on what you want to do and
just to enjoy the experience even even
the bad things are gonna happen so you
can still shapes and Mo's you who you
are think about things you wanted went
through a life of like I would never do
that again but it still prepares you to
be able to look out for anything else or
to do anything else so
yeah cuz kids even if I were to write a
book right now I think would be very
informative but at the same time it's
it's everybody else is their journey so
it's nothing in particular I can get
from that I said we just get as much
knowledge as you can
you